it's always fun to talk to you know the
team here super excited about it i mean
there's there's like 10 different things
we can talk about with you uh although
i'll start with kind of who you are in
your background just so to get everyone
on the same page you know you're
fundamentally a writer what you know
right when you came out of college you
worked for you went to be a writer in
london and then in new orleans which is
where both of us grew
up um
what was it early on in your life that
kind of convinced you that you wanted to
be a writer that you this is something
that you would kind of find meaning in
yeah sal and i both grew up in new
orleans and i had a sort of an uncle in
new orleans by uncle by marriage and we
never knew what uncle walker did because
he was always at home you know drinking
bourbon and eating hog said cheese north
of lake pontchartrain on the boga fly
and we say ann what does your dad do and
say well he's a writer and i was like 9
or 10 years old and it was only after
you know about i think i was age 11 or
so the moviegoer comes out by walker
percy and he's a great but was a great
southern novelist
and i i realized that being a writer was
something you could do just like being
an engineer or a fisherman or a doctor
or whatever and like you could actually
be a writer and you got to sit home all
day and drink bourbon which seemed to
upside to the whole writing gig and so i
would you know grill walker percy and
say tell me about it how do you do this
or whatever and then i read his novel
by that point he'd come out with the
last gentleman as well i read them
carefully and they always were about
faith
and growth is when you were in high
school yeah it was when i was about
14 years so you were able to track him
down and and well
so we would go fishing on the boat you
know fly or right you know covington
and um
we had a place up there our family and
the percies did and we're all kind of
related so we'd go waterskiing his
daughter anne was my age and we would
water ski the bugafly and capture
turtles and do whatever you did when you
were 14 years old and try to flirt with
anne but we didn't know how to flirt
well but we could catch turtles well and
um
so uh then you know i would get home and
i'd i'll get to their house and i'd say
you know tell me about this thing
and i asked him about the novels and the
sort of the themes and the philosophical
themes and the preaching he said look
there are two types of people come out
of louisiana preachers and storytellers
he said for god's sake be a storyteller
the world's got far too many preachers
and so i realized that storytelling was
sort of a way
that you could make sense of the world
you know make people understand things
better i said well that's what i want to
do i want to be a writer and i don't
want to be
an opinion writer i want to be a
storyteller writer and did you have
doubt that you're a teenager now you
know did people tell you that hey it's
hard to be a writer or this is kind of a
be a doctor well i had i mean it wasn't
like okay i'm a teenager i'm going to be
a writer i was a teenager and then you
know went to college and i actually
studied philosophy in college and then
went to graduate school and studied
philosophy so there was a moment i
thought i might be a philosopher
although i didn't quite know whether i
don't know in this strip here whether
somebody says you're a philosopher and
you go in and they i didn't quite know
how you become a philosopher but i was
actually thinking of you know being an
academic and
even showed my undergraduate uh
professors the thesis i'd written in
england
and they said no you'd probably be
better off being a journalist and so it
was at that point that i joined the
sunday times of london then uh what is
now the times picayune of new orleans
and and what was that that first i mean
you know and and walter's extremely
humble i mean you were you know to go
from
a lot not a lot of kids go from
louisiana to harvard to rhodes scholar
you did sort of i didn't do the last
part you did mit yeah then like anyway
but the um
we're not that much of a backwater
yes that's right a lot of people go
that's right okay that's right ellen
degeneres went to my high school really
yeah did you go to harvard
i don't think so okay that's um
but
king high school is getting away i know
we're trying yeah you went to the newman
fancy school where anyway um
me and michael lewis yeah fewer people
from grace king go to anyway um
i love it when you and i are doing a
competition on our humble ribs
and gonna watch i didn't do a lot of
turtle cats yeah yeah um
but but you know so you're kind of a
young adult at this point you graduate
like what did you how did you find that
first experience you know there's kind
of this romantic notion of being a
writer and you know when you're in
college and you're doing your thesis
you're you know you're doing philosophy
but then there's this kind of real world
of kind of being on the beat and writing
stories about the local whatever it
might be i mean what was that a
disappointment was it exciting was it a
mix you know i loved it i i started off
at the picayune
but i had gotten a summer internship at
the washington post it was the summer of
watergate right and it's just 74. all
about to break nixon was gonna resign
and either foolishly or not i decided
not to do it and i worked for t smith
and sons of stevedores on the
mississippi river at the you know the
napoleon avenue wharfs and stuff because
i wanted to write a novel about the
river so i decided okay i should work
the river like mark twain did or
something
and so i missed all of watergate i still
have the novel i wrote that summer
that's excruciatingly bad i mean you
know it's about the river and all that
sort of thing and i realized well gee i
will never be a novelist and then went
into journal so you actually you were on
a boat
well these are called derrick barges you
know if you look at the wars and there's
these
flatbed barges but they have a crane on
them and they get pushed around by what
look like tugboats what we call them
push boats because they actually you
know they don't tug the thing they push
the thing until you go up and down the
river in a very lazy way on incredibly
hot because these things had creosote
metal
and you'd have to put the creosote on
the metal you had to wear very thick
sold shoes because the deck got so hot
that it would burn your feet and the
other thing i remember which i loved
was every time the barge started up the
you know the crane started up the
electricity would go back on and we had
a percolate or coffee percolator and so
it would re-percolate the coffee all day
until it was almost the consistency of
the crea creosote and i love that really
strong coffee and so when you were
working on it and you said hey can i
work here and also like write oh yeah
could you
yeah i mean it was a really high i mean
i don't want to sound too romantic it
was also an incredibly high paid job at
that time the port in the early 70s was
booming the extraction industries oil
natural gas sulfur were going really
well
i don't know why but i mean it was the
70s and so you could make i can't
remember the dollars but you also made
double time and then two and a half
times if we work sunday's overtime
and so i just made enough to last me
through college so it's partly for the
money and partly for the romanticism of
writing a novel and yeah i mean you
couldn't sit there on the derrick barge
and type a novel but you'd sort of meet
all the people and all the boats coming
up and down and there's your unloaded
boats you're going and so i'd gather
stories and at night i'd go home and
write it up and it was
really bad
i mean you joke about it now but
obviously this is something you care
deeply about you know this idea of being
a writer this idea of being a novelist i
mean what was
i guess one what made you think that
this wasn't cut out for you but also
what allowed you to not give up writing
altogether
well
you know i actually liked
non-fiction too i mean to be able to
tell and when i started working for the
picayune
i was on police speed and you get these
wonderful wacky stories i mean jim
garrison was trying clay shaw for the
murder of the president and president
kennedy i mean i don't know if you
remember
jim jim garrison's best friends was my
ap american history teacher's
father oh
so that's all thank you really close to
that story
american history can we just go to the
white board and wrap that up
he's kind of yeah well i don't know
my
friends or my teacher's father-in-law
anyway yeah there's a word so there are
all these wacky people including uh jim
garrison who was followed by harry
connick whose son is the cornet and
trumpet player um so they're all these
wonderful tales in new orleans and there
was a rush
i i don't quite know what it is but
there's a rush which every day almost i
would have a story and often on the
front page because if you're covering
crime you get on the front page and
there you were you'd tell these stories
and your name would be in the paper
and so it wasn't like i was lamenting
the fact that i hadn't yet written the
great american novel or the great novel
about the river i kept thinking i would
and then eventually after i wrote my
first book or two i showed it an updated
version of the novel to my agent who
was not um
in any way encouraging and said no you
know but they liked your biography
right well they like
the non-fiction was doing well so and
you know in some ways if you take steve
jobs
or you take this book
i write narratives i mean i don't write
analytical non-fiction so these are
stories and i tell you
if you wrote a novel that was word for
word that's steve jobs book people say
well that's not
you know credible it doesn't feel like
it could possibly be true
therefore it's not a good novel but in
some ways with a piece of narrative
non-fiction
you know you can try to make it into the
same type of tale a novel would be now
obviously um
you know i consider people who are truly
creative novelists to be
in a quantum orbit you know above ours
i was once going to a writers conference
and betsy my daughter i think you may
have met
said dad why are you going to a writer i
said well because you know she says well
dad you're not a real writer you write
non-fiction and so you know we know it's
not quite the same but i do think
if you're telling a tale
and you try to make it a storytelling
type thing meaning chronological
narrative
you can have that excitement of watching
people grow ideas forming one thing
leading to another
and and so you i mean with that in mind
you have this kind of parallel life or
maybe it's not so parallel you uh times
picayune
then you go work start working for time
magazine which is kind of you know the
big piece of your your career at time
magazine eventually you're you're the
editor-in-chief
but at the same time you're this
biographer and you and you're you're not
you kind of take on like these
larger-than-life characters franklin
einstein jobs um
are those i mean were those two
different jobs that you had in your head
or were they were they two or they the
similar type of role writing for time
magazine eventually becoming
editor-in-chief well um
when i started at time i did it with a
friend of mine
who had gone to college with a guy named
devin thomas who you may have heard of
and we were frustrated because at time
magazine you know this isn't a previous
century let me remind you there was no
website you didn't have to tweet every
day you came out once a week usually
with like two pages you wrote so it
wasn't the hardest job and the heaviest
lifting you know in america
and in fact it was boring at times like
monday tuesday wednesday you're sitting
around trying to figure out what am i
supposed to be doing
um and then you got frustrated because
you'd go out and you report the story
and you had to keep it to what would say
be 2 000 words
and so i was covering the campaign of
1980 ronald reagan you know jimmy carter
ted kennedy i mean some larger than life
dudes and
um
so i said to evan
you know we're not getting the stuff in
the magazine i mean we just get to you
know we should do a story on the great
american establishment and how it
created the post-war world and we'd
never written a book before um
and it was about six friends that nobody
had ever heard of dean hatches and april
harriman bob lovett
and
uh we walked down the street in a place
where we had a summer house uh sag
harbor and there was an editor alice
mayhew and we said we want to do this
book and she said i've always wanted to
do a book like that it's a prequel to
the best and the brightest which is
albert sam's book about vietnam in other
words it leads into it and i've always
wanted to call it the wise men because
it was about these people
and so
we got to write this book and
it was oddly successful i think it was
very very long
and so people couldn't quite finish it
so they had to say it was good you know
they couldn't whatever it was it did
well
and
it made me think well this is really
great writing narratives about people
the other thing about time magazine then
and when i was editor we always put a
person on the cover
it was a henry luce who invented the
magazine mantra tell the story of our
time through people the people who make
it somebody said well you're like
inventing personality journalism he said
no time didn't invent that the bible did
that's how it works you know adam eve
moses you do it through people and so
um that got me interested in a
biographical way of looking at the world
huh and and what's your and so i i guess
to some degree they were complementary
skills the the biographies allowed you
to go much deeper than just the
um and what's you know as you go into i
was it late 90s you start you transition
in i guess time becomes part of time
warner
you become ceo and chairman of cnn which
doesn't seem like a natural jump it
wasn't and it was a very unnatural
jump which i didn't want to make and i
shouldn't have made you make mistakes in
life
and that was a two-headed mistake for me
as you said time warner owned both and i
had finished my stint as editor of time
and they kept pushing me to do it
it was a mistake because i didn't like
the medium i just don't like television
i'm not very good at it i don't know how
to make tv and i realized i was a pretty
good editor of the magazine simply
because i knew every detail of how it
was done
meaning
if somebody came back and said you know
we can't get it you know i had been
you know in russia or or poland during
the fall of computers but i'd covered
these things
i also had you know design pages so i
could say okay no crop the picture this
way and you can do it in 2000 words but
leave out this part and make it a
narrative and there's a billboard graph
that will say all of that and get that
out of the way or something i mean some
people are great and they can be the
head of proctor and gamble and then be
the head of united airlines and then you
know be a professor and do also things
me i i kind of knew how to do what i
knew how to do
and i shouldn't have gone into a field
where i didn't know it
secondly
i'm not a great executive manager i'm
not somebody who likes bossing people
around and at time it was quite easy
because they're only like 60 or 70
people that i deal with i mean two
floors of the building you could walk
around at cnn there were like 6 000
people and i was supposed to be this
manager and i realized i like it when
people have to manage me rather than me
having to manage them
and so i didn't like
that executive role and so that was a
three-year detour that was not something
i enjoyed and then and then you go go to
your current position which is right
head of head of the house my contract
was up by well i mean we had uh
unfortunately 911 and then the war
the first i mean
the iraq war i guess the second out of
three iraq wars now depending on how you
count them and so i waited through the
end of that my contract was up and it
was like
i want to write books i want to be
involved in you know thought and
bringing people together and doing
things
and
the aspen institute came on and what's
your role
what do you see as the role of the aspen
institute is this kind of really
interesting organization sal has joined
our board it's a great organization been
around 60 years
and it's partly a think tank we have
policy programs and everything from the
environment education whatever
it's partly a tank that does things i
mean we have middle east loan funds
we're working with khan academy to try
to you know put together american civics
courses uh but it's also and i wish
there were a better word for it it seems
like a you know a 50 cent word for 25
product which is uh convening we bring
people together and that's something
that you particularly don't have in
washington or other places these days
where democrats republicans left right
people of different persuasions
come together sit around tables spend a
few days together exchange ideas it's
particularly interesting to me that in
the digital age when we thought that we
could all skype and
you know do things on google hangouts
and
chat rooms and live virtually
there is actually more of a hunger for
in-person meetings this is why you have
a room like this is why people hang out
and
uh and in some ways googleplex beats
google hangouts having a nice
environment like this and so the aspen
institute has grown quite a bit through
ideas festivals and many other things
which is where people are watching
things on youtube doing khan academy
videos but at the end of which they kind
of say okay now let's get together i
want to
be in flesh and discuss it
and and so that that's i think what's
interesting about you i mean you have
this
you're a historian now at the aspen
institute you're kind of a convener
you're very plugged into kind of the
current state of affairs even in
washington but you're also
intimately involved in silicon valley
you know you're this the latest book the
which isn't even out yet
not until next month
it's a it's a history of silicon valley
especially um and obviously you've done
the bio it actually starts at your alma
mater mit with the
tech model railway club and the people
creating space war and all the people in
the late 40s who come up with both video
games and hands-on computing but then it
moves west and it tries to explain why
people like yourself move from mit to
the valley and and and that's what's
fascinating because it's you know it's a
history about kind of something that is
defining the future uh and you also have
this kind of this aspen institute
kind of what's going on in dc and so
with this kind of futurist historian hat
i mean where do you think we are like
you know it's very easy for us to get
caught up in the you know what's going
on week by week you know
you're on the apple board apple
announced his new iphone today all this
all this all this craziness but you know
25 years from now 50 years from now 500
years from now how are people going to
think about
now
yeah i think they'll think about it just
as they thought a hundred years ago
about 1840 and the industrial revolution
where you start having steam engines and
mechanized products and it changes
the whole way i mean instead of people
artisans weaving fabrics it's now done
and it changes employment and everything
else so i think you have that disruption
i think we're at the stage of the
digital revolution where we're just
getting out of pouring old wine into new
bottles it you know for the first 20 30
years of the revolution
we had the internet we had online we had
computers but we were still taking you
know op-ed pieces and pouring them
online and calling them you know blogs
or something or we were taking time
magazine and putting it on the web and
it would be an online you know time
online
but we weren't inventing whole new
things
there were three or four industries that
did not get disrupted which gets back to
khan academy
early on
uh health care and medicine did not get
disrupted the way it should have and
k-12 education i mean i wrote about ben
franklin he invented a type of school
that he called the academy for the
education of youth and what it was was
about 24 people kid sitting in a row and
a teacher in front and a blackboard and
a lecturer and then a test
that was you know whatever 1740
and you flash ahead you know two and a
half centuries and we're still doing it
that way so the disruption you all in
this room are bringing
to
k through 12 education and the your book
the one
schoolhouse
that's beginning to kick in so the next
phase is when we quit pouring old wine
and new bottles and frankly the first
people doing online learning and stuff
it was simply taking a camera pointing
it in sanders theater to mike sandel and
he would give a lecture and they would
call that an online course
i do think especially with edx you're
seeing a platform that does it quite
differently now and has a feedback or
it's a feedback loop so you say okay
that works that doesn't likewise you're
doing it much differently you're not
just
putting a high school course online and
that's what i mean about new wine for
the new bottle so we're getting into
that age i think there's a lot still to
be done
i mean books have not been disrupted
i wanted with steve jobs to nail my
whole book later and still don't have it
happen i want to take a book and write
it and curate it but i want it to be
open source like wikipedia
i want everybody in that book from
wozniak to bill gates to
uh dan brooklyn or you know stuart brand
i mean they don't have to be major
characters or even people aren't in the
book but have oh i have this video i was
at this long to be able to put stuff up
so you write a collaborative book that's
multimedia people are putting up the
code they wrote for the first basic
interpreter for the altair and somebody
else is putting up the circuit design
for the altair in the book and somebody
else is saying here's the video of
steve's first launch of the apple two
that sort of thing
and
if you had a collaborative project like
that that i think should be curated
because i'm a control freak i don't want
everybody just to put whatever they want
but i want and i i was working with ev
williams yesterday i don't know if you
know he is but he did twitter but now
does medium i put some of my chapters on
medium and people could put comments and
things in but i could reject them or i
could include them and so it gives me
some curatorial power and then
eventually we'll have to have payment
systems where especially i mean i'm not
trying to do this you know if the money
now
if my book is written and 40 percent of
it is people have collaborated and
crowdsourced it
when people read those sections there
should be some metering and the royalty
should go just like if a song is played
on the radio the original composer
that's on gets a fraction of a cent
royalty we ought to have ways to
collaboratively crowdsource things and
to allocate royalties based on that
that's just one example of where i think
things might go i wanted always to do a
book on our hometown boy louis armstrong
and i want to do it with winton marsalis
and i want linton to be able to say okay
when we do west end blues we see him
take this 17 bars and
you know just rag it
and if i wrote that nobody know what i'm
talking about but if winton is saying
you know here's how kid ori did it and
now here's how lewis armstrong did it
you'd say okay i get it and so those
type of projects
we aren't there yet but i keep waiting
for those platforms to be built yeah
that's that's that's amazing the the i
mean one thing that's fascinating about
you i mean you even just mention it now
even with louis armstrong is you know
the threat of all the people that you
you write about and that kind of
especially with this book this is kind
of a combination of a bunch of folks but
whether it's franklin or einstein or
louis armstrong or or or steve jobs
they're all actually innovators
and some degree kind of scientists in
their domain
absolutely i mean different biographers
or writers are interested in different
things some people like crime choice
unlike
war heroes you know writing about
eisenhower or d-day some like sports
heroes some like
you know literary biographies they want
to write you know the biography we've
all been waiting for for you know joyce
carol oates or something um
i like people who are imaginative and
not just smart because you know you're
in this room smart people are a dime a
dozen
what really matters is being
imaginative being able to think
different to use steve's parlance
uh
and so i sort of say what makes
you know ben franklin wasn't the
smartest of the founders i think
jefferson madison he got a lot of
really sharp cookies in that box
um but franklin had a certain ability to
think more imaginatively to be more
creative what makes for creativity and i
don't know that i set out i like to
think okay and when people ask me if
they're not a friend and i'm you know
i'm being more honest with you i always
say yeah i've always tried to write
about creativity how it happens how
people think differently
actually you know i wrote about
kissinger was you know believe it or not
a very creative thinker in the balance
of power he did with russia and china
during our extrication from vietnam
and then obviously franklin einstein but
it wasn't like i started out saying let
me make a list of people who have
thought imaginatively it was only you
know two or three books into it that
said well that's sort of the theme that
i keep exploring
and what do you think it is i mean you
mentioned this it's not necessarily
their kind of raw mental horsepower
that's doing it i mean do you think it's
just this kind of a like a creativity
gene or do you think it's something that
they developed and that they cultivated
and they well the good news is there's
not a one sentence answer which is why
you get to write 600 page biographies
instead of saying here's the answer you
don't need to read the book however part
of it
i do think is being able
to connect
the arts or humanities having a real
feel for beauty let us say with
technology engineering and science
and if you
i'm sure some of you actually worked at
apple
i don't know i assume tim did not do it
today but and every one of steve's
launches the last thing on the screen
would be that intersection of the
streets the liberal arts
and the sciences i think it was or
technology whatever and he said you know
and it's the very first i think pages of
my book he says you know when i was a
kid i loved the humanities but i was
also an electronics geek and then i read
something that edwin land who invented
polaroid set which is if you stand at
that intersection of the arts and the
sciences that's where true value is
that's you know what leonardo da vinci
did that's what uh and so i think that's
one of the secrets of true creativity
far too often is why the khan academy
videos are important to me and i think
are great and why your whole learning
growth thing is important
if you're a humanities person meaning
you've studied you know literature the
arts maybe history
you get intimidated by science and
math and it's odd maybe not people you
know but people i know would even brag
like oh i don't know math i couldn't
tell you an integral from a differential
equation or transistor from a resistor
or a gene from a chromosome
they would never brag about saying i
couldn't tell you hamlet from macbeth or
i couldn't you know
and so it's socially acceptable not to
know math and science and that should
not be the case and that's why i wrote
the einstein book in particular because
part of our problem of the cp snows two
cultures problem comes from einstein
it's not his personal fault but up until
then
the newton mechanical universe was
something the average person
benjamin franklin thomas jefferson they
all could pretty much understand you
know the laws of motion the you know
equal and opposite reactions balances it
you read it in the constitution the
balances that come in with einstein
suddenly you know time is relative and
you know
gravity bends light and
the quantum
you know
at the sub-atomic level and quantum
mechanics you know we're not have a
strict deterministic laws that and whoa
all of a sudden science becomes
something that the average person can't
cope with
yeah yeah but that's i but kind of
that's part of what you're saying is
that in order for some of these folks to
that kind of culture is in the wrong
place right now it's not favoring more
of the creativity innovation because
there's a lot of very smart people
probably on either side of that right
that venn diagram who are afraid to go
into that intersection
yeah and i'm trying to say if you look
at ben franklin the most important
scientist of his period even though you
probably know you know we think of him
as a daughtering dude flying a kite in
the rain single fluid theory of
electricity that comes from his
electricity experiments is up there in
that century you know with newton even i
mean it's the best experimental
scientist of his time jefferson you know
would have thought you were philistine
if you didn't study botany and
everything else
nowadays people like a ben franklin
don't do electricity experiments and
even when i was growing up
i'm in a slightly different category
because my dad is an electrical engineer
all my uncles are electrical engineers
so i grew up with heath kits and ham
radios and soldering irons and
figuring out different transistors and
making circuits
but many kids in the 60s did that and
there's a problem now too that
if you're a computer kid growing up
today you're not even allowed to change
the battery in your computer much less
you know screw with the circuit board
yeah yeah
and you know kind of taking that to this
book which is you know as we said it's
about kind of the the founding of kind
of this tech revolution that we're in
silicon valley i mean when you wrote
this book i'm sure this is something
that you've been thinking about
especially when you did the steve jobs
book what do you think is special about
either silicon valley or that the time
we're in now that it's allowing it to be
what it is
yeah i mean there are multiple layers of
this one is why is the united states
tend to still even with the 17th best
education system in the world meaning
we're not the best educated these days
but we still invent more things and get
invented in other countries and secondly
why was there a migration in silicon
valley in particular in the 70s let's
say i have a whole chapter besides
writing about people you also have to
write about
cultural forces i mean
you know history is also cultural forces
not just
people doing things
and in the late 60s and early 70s
you had a lot of movements out here
one was sort of the hobbyist movement
the other was
electronics because
westinghouse and all the defense
industries coming but but also there
were two counter-cultural movements the
hippie movement with a lot of
you know um
personal empowerment and
you know
and likewise the anti-war movement and
the free speech movement at berkeley and
they all come together in the bay area
with a lot of great music you know with
this soundtrack by the grateful dad and
it's rebellious
it's personally empowering it's defiant
of authority all of these
and
it creates an atmosphere
where the computer which had been
thought of as a big
orwellian george orwell
type thing that governments and the
military
and big corporations got to have
it's like no
there's a wonderful
the homebrew computer club had a
newsletter and it's computer powered to
the people was a mantra and that played
off the power to the people mantra of
the 60s and 70s in this area
so you had that cultural
stew that milieu i remember talking to
tim berners-lee obviously the guy who
creates the web protocols
and he said i'm the exact same age as
steve jobs and bill gates born in 1955
you know my generation
he said i was doing the same thing they
were every time a new electronic
component would come along like i knew
transistors that was really cool and
then i figured out okay microchips come
along i can make more things a whole
microprocessor so i went to oxford and i
was
you know their same age as woz and steve
and all
and
i created my home computer the way they
did a circuit board
he said and then i got to oxfordshire
and what was i supposed to do with it
there was no vintage there was no guy
driving up like don valentine to the
steve jobs family garage and saying i'll
fund you make this into a company and so
he said we didn't have that
entrepreneurial stew and that rebellious
spirit in england that you had in the
valley and where do you think we are now
where do you think you think the valley
do you think this is you know what's the
next 30 years going to look like you
think it's only gaining more momentum
it's definitely changed no and i don't
want to i mean
this you may not all definitely want to
hear it because i love the valley but i
think when you the next phase as i said
is the connection of the creativity
industries with technology and it's not
as much of an engineer driven game as a
creativity driven whether you're in
fashion or journalism or playwriting or
rpgs and larps or whatever it is that
makes you creative the tying in of
creativity to
technology
is the creation of the new wine for the
engineered bottles that we now have and
that's why i think you're seeing san
francisco property values i just
came late last night from san francisco
and i was even at the pier 48 area where
you just stand outside and watch condos
rise and they you know people are
bidding wars for them
and uh so i think
that's something you and i have talked
about mountain view palo alto whatever
how are you going to have a more
cultural you know culturally rich life
for creative people who want to do
things like you know go to talks go to
plays go to music go to whatever there
is some of that here but not as much as
in san francisco so you want to build up
the magnet of creativity and diversity
you and i know growing up in new orleans
if you have blacks and creoles and
vietnamese and spanish and people coming
back from spanish-american war and the
sanctified church and you know italians
and everything else all in the
neighborhood then you're going to get a
stew that produces jazz
so i think you know one of the things
for the next few years would be how do
you have the diversity and the
creativity everywhere why is austin
doing well others and i think that's a
challenge for mountain view in palo alto
and a challenge that's easily met but
and i guess the second big trend
is some of the technology that's coming
up will be biotech not infotech
and that's harder to do in garages i
mean that's wet wear not software
and you kind of need the big hospital
systems and other things which is why
your old haunts of mit and harvard may
get a second uh
bite of the apple uh no pun intended
yeah
and and kind of just to kind of put
everything together you know we're doing
this whole campaign around you know you
can learn anything around
mindset i mean given all of your
experience and the people who you have
known interviewed
studied
i mean what would you tell to a
young person who uh maybe a person who
considers themselves good at writing but
is fearful of math or someone who
considers himself good at math and is
fearful of writing what advice would you
have for them well since i'm not a
preacher i'm a storyteller i'll tell a
story which is that einstein was no
einstein when he was a kid he was slow
in learning how to talk so you know so
slow they consult the doctor and and the
family maid calls him dude
the dopey one in the family and so it
takes him a while
he doesn't
he's not able to do things in a verbal
way as easily so he thinks in pictures
what he calls thought experiments like
what would happen if lightning
struck both ends of a moving train would
you see it the same if you're on the
train on the platform all of his great
breakthroughs are done through visual
thought experiments so you begin by
thinking if einstein was no einstein
when he was a kid i can be anything if i
want to learn
also it's why i like journalism and why
i like doing what i do which is every
day i could learn something different i
could be in eastern europe and try to
figure out why communism was falling and
then i could go to cern and figure out
what they were going to do with the
higgs boson particle if they found it i
had to learn these things and for me
once i got successful enough as a
biographer that's when i bit off things
like einstein
partly because i wanted to tell people
hey
you should learn
and that you shouldn't be intimidated by
science but partly i want to tell myself
which is
can i understand general relativity i
first got turned on to khan academy
when i had to learn tensor calculus
which is not so much in the book but i
had to understand
the tense of calculus that einstein uses
to show the curvature of the universe
or the fabric of space and time
and
i realized well i got to get all my
calculus
dusted off and i started going to khan
academy and saying okay let me boom boom
boom
and also this was a cool thing which is
you cannot you're never too old to learn
i can now
learn
not enough of general relativity then
i'm going to be able to debate brian
greene on string theory but enough that
i can talk to him about it and learn
from him yeah and and i guess just one
last question i mean what advice do you
have for us uh you're familiar with the
organization khan academy and kind of
some of our aspirations but you all you
know you have you have a historic
historian's mind
so what advice would you have for us if
we really do want to over the next 50 or
100 years become something that can
empower
billions of folks you know i'm gonna
blow smoke for a moment
which is i actually think what you're
doing is so good i mean this is why i've
been a fan this is why
you know i was felt lucky to get to know
you
um
that i've you know i watch other people
trying to do things pouring on wine new
bottles michael sandel making quote you
know which is now a good course but it
took a while
i think what you're doing really is
defining it very well
how learning can work
i've tried to do
one additional angle in our work with
you which is my belief
that people can learn alone by doing
these videos and it's good because they
can learn at their own pace but there's
something that's probably the oldest
philosophy around which is aristotle's
which is man is a social animal that in
the end people kind of like getting
together that it's a collaborative
personal
group process of learning and exchanging
ideas so i i've pushed a little bit
we've been trying to do with the aspen
institute is to combine the online
learning with the play space convening
which is if you
get through this course and you do this
essay and you pass it and you
not only do you get a badge and
something signed by sal and everything
else
but you can apply for scholarships
because we'll raise the money and you
can come to say we do something as we're
doing now on privacy in the constitution
with sandra day o'connor and justice
roberts and a few other people say okay
you take that course
and if you do well apply for one of
these things and we'll pick a hundred
scholars from around the country who
finish the course and you get to go to
philadelphia and sit down with sandra
day o'connor have a weekend you come to
washington and you get to hang out at
the supreme court
and get to meet the other people did the
course with you so i think combining
virtual learning with place based
learning which is obviously something
you write about in one room schoolhouses
obviously things that rocketship have
done that's the next phase of the
revolution is how do you blend it in
because we're never
going to be
something aristotle wouldn't recognize
we're never going to be people who like
to learn alone
i think it was franklin who said
i know it was franklin and i think what
he said was
he that would try to learn alone or
drink alone would be like the person who
tries to catch his horse alone it's
something you have to do with other
people
this is why i don't get asked to speak
at high school graduations that often or
college graduations
almost every one of my characters drops
out and runs away einstein
you know hate school drops out in
germany runs away to switzerland ben
franklin runs away to philadelphia steve
jobs drops out of reed
and uh i guess that's all franklin and
uh kisser doesn't i mean it's the nazis
take over so it's a different issue um
but uh
all of them are rebellious in a way they
all run away from home
and that makes them in some ways more
open to learning experiences i think or
to think out of the box
i mean one way to answer is i go back
and forth about writing that current
figures and writing historical figures
um
and so
i um
and you know there's a different set of
muscles you need if you're going to
interview somebody like steve jobs the
interesting thing about the innovators
is it's both historical you know people
like john von neumannelle and touring
who obviously i never got to meet and do
it through archival research but then
people like bill gates or steve jobs who
spend hours and hours
allowing me to interview them so i try
to do the mix there
i think you have to always put someone
in historical context
but you also have to judge them by how
history turned out the best example is
slavery
in the end i don't think jefferson was a
great man
in the end he didn't even free his
slaves and you say well you have to
understand the historical period he was
back then and that's what they did no
benjamin franklin now uh also at one
point
had two household slaves
and it occurs to him how abhorrent that
is and so he becomes the president of
the society for the abolition of slavery
so this is the great debate in history
which is do you judge people by their
period or do you say no
history proved them wrong
and that's something we judge them by
i'm a little bit in the latter camp even
the churchill who's a great man
but
so against the anti-colonial you know
against gandhi against everything else
well you look at history he was on the
wrong side of that one so as great as he
was during world war ii you say
no um
you know even though a lot of people
were racist and anti-semitic and you
know pro-colonial and everything else
back then not that he was anti-semitic
but you know people
you don't just say yeah i excuse them
because that's the way they were at the
time you say no
these people turned out to be better
than these people
well two things i would like to invent
the new wine for the new bottle i would
like to invent a collab what i told you
about a collaborative multimedia
crowd-sourced yet
curated
guided new thing that people would say
oh yes when gutenberg did the moveable
type printing press
pretty soon afterwards lots of things
happened the reformation would have but
even novels begin to happen you can have
novels if you have a printing press
i want to say i was involved
in figuring out what type of new
narrative
non-fiction and it can be fiction but
i'm
probably leave that to somebody else
just like if it's fiction you would say
okay let's take role-playing games and
larps and blah blah and say how we're
going to have interactive
storytelling fiction i want to do that
with non-fiction
and i think that would be cool i've been
somewhat involved over the years
and not truly inventing the future like
the real innovators but i ran
a digital media time inc in the early
90s and we
it was right when the web browser was
first invented which is i think 93 or 94
when mosaic comes out of university of
illinois
and we said okay let's create websites
and even we invented some things that
probably weren't good like banner ads
and pop-up ads and ways to pay for
things we do
and i was part of the team that you know
invented some of those things i'm not
going to take blame or credit for but at
least i was in that mix of people who
said we will create websites we will
take
news and journalism and invent you know
things like pathfinder i mean new
brand names that would create
ways of doing news and blogs and
integrate them and we had a lot of
failures i mean one of which is
we were totally advertising dependent
because we were making so much money on
ads so we didn't become reader dependent
and so we began catering to advertisers
another is that we took the community
that we had created before the web was
invented the community you found on the
well or america online where people had
bulletin boards and chat rooms and every
night they'd be discussing issues and we
relegated those to comments on the
bottom of articles that were stupid
anonymous dumb and nobody read them so
we went we went from being a community
service to being a publishing service
online and that was a step backward i
like to think we did some things that
were kind of good though like create
uh beautiful web pages and designs where
you integrated words and multimedia and
video and pictures and that was sort of
a new
thing when we created those
you know in pathfinder and hotwire did
it better than we did
a lot of the early websites of 1994.
so i would like to say i want one more
turn at the wheel on invention
and i have a couple of biographies that
are just plain old biographies that i'm
going to write including a historical
one about the ultimate guy
leonardo da vinci who combines art
and um
science like nobody else did well no
it's a great note to end on well thank
you so much walter it was a real real
honor
my honor
you